throughout the saw franchise there have
been many symbols and images associated
with jigsaw from puzzle pieces to
spirals to
the pigs which are hidden in many of the
crime scenes in this ninth movie the
very first victim is targeted at a
carnival where you can spot this pig on
the fun house mural and a man holding a
pig balloon the meaning behind the pig
symbol has changed a couple of times now
it started as a reference to the year of
the pig in the chinese zodiac which was
representative of the eastern ideas that
jigsaw incorporated into his teachings
and at some point it became a symbol of
compassion towards those in suffering
did you know that pigs are highly
compassionate animals
they show distress if they see any other
animal
including humans suffering in spiral
there's a new jigsaw copycat who is in
new context for the use of the pig
symbol it's a reference to the
derogatory
term that people sometimes use towards
police officers the new killer is
targeting dirty cops and so he
ironically uses the pig costume and
symbol to give them a taste of their own
brutality that's why the puppet avatar
has been changed this time to a creepy
pig perhaps the dirtiest police officer
detective fitch even has a coffee mug
decorated with pig imagery he discovers
a pig mask shortly before going into his
trap and a pig falls out of the car when
the police discover where the killer
deposited fitch's fingers
other less noticeable pig symbols
include the pig models displayed in the
butcher shop where one of the other
victims is discovered
including this adorable little pig chef
and the pig mask hiding in the
background as zeke enters the church to
find pete dunleavy his number one
suspect
to learn how each trap in spiral evolved
from one of john kramer's traps in the
original saw movie
stick around to the end of this video
this video is sponsored
by lionsgate
[Music]
spiral is the newest chapter in the book
of saw and it's now available on digital
blu-ray and 4k
if you watch my channel you may remember
when i thought the book of saw was going
to be an actual book in the movie
that didn't age too well the movie stars
chris rock max mingella marisol nichols
and samuel l jackson
daryn lynn bausman who directed saws 2 3
and 4 is back to direct spiral and i
noticed some references to some of his
other work hidden in graffiti around the
city in addition to making movies he's
also done these immersive theatrical
experiences
basically expensive haunted houses where
you sign a waiver but instead of the
actors trying to scare you they just try
to make
you really uncomfortable his first one
was in 2016 and called the tension
experience and its logo can be seen
graffitied on a pillar at the 12th
street bridge
the next year he followed that up with
the lust experience whose logo was seen
spray painted on a wall at the
courthouse these experiences have their
own lore which is also referenced bos
stands for brotherhood of serif
a group inside the tension experience
universe the parcel delivery company is
osdn which stands for oracle security
and data management a fictional company
featured in the lost experience
as is par for the saw franchise there
are plenty of other references and
hidden secrets to uncover
so let's get into that
[Music]
the movie opens with the normal not
spooky lionsgate logo i guess the new
saw films
are just not going to do that anymore
how sad detective marv boswick is lured
away from the 4th of july carnival when
he chases a purse thief ironically
stealing a purse was a punishable
offense in the eyes of john kramer in
the previous movie jigsaw when boswick
gets down into the subway tunnel he
realizes he's been bamboozled when his
suspect has been replaced by a mannequin
that could have been his first clue that
he was dealing with a jigsaw copycat you
may remember john's first ever workshop
in saw one was in a mannequin factory we
come to learn that the new copycat
detective shank believes in john
kramer's philosophy but has his own
ideas about who it should be applied to
john kramer was right spiral
symbol of change evolution progress
but why limit that to an individual when
you can apply it to a whole system
so it makes sense that a lot of shanks
traps seem to be evolutions of the
jigsaw traps the subway trap is a lot
like the classroom trap from saw three
each one requires the victim to tear
something out of their body to escape
before time runs out
there are also obvious parallels to the
trap from jill's dream in saw7 and yes i
prefer to call it sauce evidence that it
saw 3d so we get used to it but i'm not
actually counting this one as an
inspiration for shank because it was
just a dream we have no proof that it
was ever a real trap it is interesting
how it contains the spiral logo though
there are a couple of red herrings that
could be placed to lead the audience
into thinking that certain characters
are responsible for the subway trap
chief bank seems to be a trained fanatic
and decorates his apartment with
pictures of locomotives and the drug
dealer has a nine and three quarters
tattoo a reference to the famous magical
train platform in harry potter buzz is
unable to escape the subway trap on time
and the train that hits him has a big
eye
x on the front the saw films have always
been labeled with roman numerals and
this is the numeral for the number nine
spiral is the ninth film in the
franchise then we meet detective zeke
banks who is working undercover with a
gang of thieves who are in a heated
discussion about the fate of forrest
gump
i don't see no sequel where's gump 2
it's almost like a statement to the fans
about mark hoffman hoffman was jigsaw's
successor the main villain of movies 4-7
who was assumed dead after being
game-overed in his last appearance
he didn't appear in the next sequel
jigsaw this isn't a perfect analogy
though for one there is a sequel to
forrest gump the novel just never got a
movie adaptation like the first one did
and for two josh stolberg the
co-screenwriter of jigsaw and spiral
who's probably the most likely candidate
to write satan has publicly tweeted
about the issue
stating that while he didn't write the
last movie to include hoffman he
personally thinks that he's alive
speaking of hoffman you'll notice that
this isn't the same police station that
hoffman annihilated in saw7
that was the metro pd 13th precinct
while this is the south metro police
station so we're dealing with a
different part of the same city but
there is a nice reference to the 13th
precinct in this movie
perhaps both buildings were created by
the same architect because the evidence
room in spiral has a very similar layout
to the evidence room from saw7 detective
banks gets the call to investigate the
train accident
it's impossible to say for sure but is
that saw one director james wan sitting
by the window on the train
one interesting thing about spiral is
that nearly every previous saw director
was involved in some way
james wan was an executive producer
daryn lynn bausman directed it david
hackl was a visual consultant and kevin
gruesert was an executive producer
that leaves the spirit brothers who
directed jigsaw as the only saw
directors not to work on spyral
however i did find a detail that may in
fact be a massive jigsaw connection
it comes when zeke is interrogating
boswick's wife roland
in the last few weeks did you notice
anything unusual
there was one thing there was a black
suv parked outside one night last week
and he went out and he walked up and i
don't know the next thing i know he was
yelling at somebody inside
this is never brought up again in the
movie which i find a little strange
jigsaw also had unanswered questions
like this for example when the
pathologist eleanor makes it out of the
pig farm she waves down a car
then looks concerned as she sees who's
driving it we can't really tell if it's
black but it does look to be roughly the
size of an suv
nelson also drives a gray suv it could
look black at night
maybe a future sequel will provide the
answer we never really get any follow-up
about zeke's wife and kid either just as
logan nelson's kid was a seemingly
unfinished storyline in jigsaw
as the police realize they've got a
jigsaw copycat on their hands they study
what they know about john kramer
including this screenshot from saw 4
mugshots of abi tate and addison corday
from saw 2
magazine and newspaper articles from
various movies primarily saw four
this photo of john which is from the
journal of civil engineering first scene
in soft four and this screenshot of
billy the puppet which is from the
classroom trap in saw three in addition
to all of that the corkboards contain
maps and photos from the night of
detective boswick's death and photos of
what appears to be another crime scene
involving a knife this may in fact be a
leftover from a scene that was cut from
the movie apparently this trap involved
someone's face getting cut off and they
had to submit the film to the motion
picture association 11 times just to get
it down to an r rating
one thing i've always had fun pointing
out in my previous saw franchise things
you missed episodes is the crew
reference easter eggs and this scene has
a few of them the police searched
twitter for photos taken in stuart's
point that night for anything that might
help them to identify the suspect noel
99 and nina c aren't crew members but
remember those names i'll come back to
them later the first one is raphael
pacheco a visual effects coordinator in
the corner there's a prompt to follow a
user named kiki singh who is probably
related to spyral's editor and devse
just a side note i love the idea that
police work is done by just googling
phrases related to the date of the crime
he just has tabs open with searches for
july 4 night
july 4 event and july 4 case as if
somebody has already solved the case and
just posted the answers online
we also get a little glimpse of his
email inbox where he's at exchanges with
john c
which is likely visual effects
supervisor john camphins there are more
names to spot on detective jury's tablet
like nina campins and noel campfins they
aren't listed in the credits but they're
probably related to vfx supervisor john
captains you'll also see
beau parsons beau is another visual
effects supervisor and sean morris
special effects technician no relation
the next police officer to find himself
in a trap is detective fitch who becomes
the victim of the finger trap
if each trap is inspired by one of the
original traps created by john kramer
this one definitely draws from the
electric bathtub from saw five with the
source of the danger being the
combination of water and electricity
it's possible that this was foreshadowed
in the opening shot of the movie where
one of the carnival games offers pokemon
plushies as prizes specifically you can
win squirtle or pikachu the water type
and the electric type pokemon
respectively the ferris wheel was even
blue and yellow amanda would be rocking
out if she was still here
the finger trap begins at the sound of
the buzzer
sounds exactly like the buzzer from the
pig vat trap in saw the ring
we hear the sound again later on in the
glass grinder trap where it's used to
signal the beginning of the flying glass
shards
the finger trap is designed to take away
fitch's overactive trigger fingers it's
interesting to see an actual sawtrap
that takes away your fingers because the
poster for saw two features a pair of
severed fingers but there's no finger
severing seen in the movie so i guess it
was a long time coming
the trap also takes place at a location
called the nesvit brothers breads
michael nesbitt is the movie's assistant
art director
not having heard from his father z goes
to his apartment to check on him he
comes across the old photo of him and
his dad at constantine's hobby shop
this is another crew reference easter
egg jason constantine was one of
spiral's executive producers
a new package containing another flash
drive is delivered to the police station
the next day and we get a short glimpse
of zeke's computer screen before he
plugs it in
it seems he's looking up an event from
11 11 2004 where two males got into a
fight in a parking lot
i don't think this report is relevant to
the story at all as these descriptions
don't match any important song
characters but i would note that this
would have been a matter of weeks after
the bathroom game in saw juan the date
11-11 is also significant for the
director daryn lynn bausman who directed
a horror film titled 11-11-11 about
strange events occurring on that date
the clues lead to zeke and shank to
investigate this meth dealer who may
have ties to their suspect
you think we have enough for a warrant
though who said anything about a warrant
don't we need a wire for this what you
talking about
the whole scene is packed with easter
eggs from saw four and five
you can tell we're about to get into a
throwback when they enter the grimy
apartment building with a green tinge
the signature aesthetic of the first
seven films
i'm first reminded of officer rigg's
foray into the alexander motel in saw4
where he blows by a morbidly obese man
in the tank top to go up the stairs here
we see zeke and shank do the same
at the top of the stairs there's a room
completely illuminated in red just like
the room where rig finds the evidence in
the motel
on the way up the stairs zeke is
confronted by an aggressive dog
this is almost like a perfect
reenactment of the scene at mark
hoffman's apartment in saw five
brought back in spiral is the idea of
the killer being disguised as a victim
of the game
in saw one it was jon and saw two it was
amanda in saw four it was hoffman and in
jigsaw
it was nelson this time detective shank
makes it appear as if he's been killed
only to reveal that he did this by
leaving his tattoo on the real victim's
arm
there's also a nice detail in this scene
where they go to interrogate pete
pete is the one who shot shank's father
and shank stays back behind his partner
out of fear of possibly being recognized
even though he was just a kid when they
last met the next victim is the police
captain angie garza she is trapped
inside the evidence room by the pig mast
shank
it makes sense because only a police
officer would be able to get into this
room
the door to the evidence room is secured
by vincent and jewell's safe company if
that sounds familiar it's because
vincent and jules are the two main
characters in the 1994 crime movie pulp
fiction
jules was played by actor samuel l
jackson who also plays chief marcus
banks in spyral
marcus banks is the father of zeke banks
and the only character to call him by
his full name
this may be a reference to pulp fiction
where one of the most famous scenes
features samuel l jackson quoting a
bible verse called ezekiel 25 17.
anyway captain garza is put into the wax
trap which will smother her face in hot
wax if she's unable to sever her spinal
cord with the blade under her neck
it's not really clear how this trap
works mechanically but there are a
number of jigsaw traps that share the
same concept of drowning or smothering
the victim
if they can't complete their task on
time from the pig vat and saw 3 to the
water cube and saw five to the silo and
jigsaw with those that he has deemed to
be bad cops out of the way
shank is ready for the finale of his
plan and kidnapped zeke who awakens
changed to a pipe
obviously this is a callback to the
beginning of the first movie so i'm not
even gonna count that on the things you
missed but after escaping he discovers
pete who is caught in the last jigsaw
inspired trap the glass grinder
this one is just like the freezer room
from saw three the only difference is
that instead of the victim being sprayed
with freezing water while someone tries
to find the key to set them free pete is
getting sliced apart by shards of glass
shanks hideout is in an abandoned soap
factory this is another common trait
shared with jigsaw who always used
abandoned factories as his hideouts and
locations for his games
it even has the obligatory sliding door
although nobody says the iconic line
game over in this one
the final trap is the puppet trap where
chief banks is hung up on strings and
zeke must decide between saving him or
killing shank
this one isn't really inspired by a
jigsaw trap from what i can tell but the
explanation of the trap is definitely
familiar
roll it do you know there's 1.5 gallons
of blood in the human body zeke
at the rate your old man's bleeding out
in just three minutes
those jars will be full and your dad
will be dead
the human body for instance is an
astoundingly durable
creation it contains approximately 10
pints of
blood yet it is still able to operate
with just half of that 10 pints is only
equal to 1.25 gallons i looked it up and
i guess the average body has 1.2 to 1.5
gallons of blood
so they're kind of both right in a way
this trap not only takes place behind
this wall graffitied with jigsaw spiral
symbol but it's also located at the top
of a spiral staircase
well kind of after a classic saw style
montage detective shank or if we're
calling him by his real name william
emerson
slips away in an elevator just as jigsaw
did way back in darren lin bausman's
first saw movie
saw two i want to give a big thanks to
lionsgate for sponsoring this video
check out the link in the description to
purchase your own copy of spyral but to
fully understand the world of saw you'll
need to click that playlist on the left
for things you missed episodes on every
single movie remember to subscribe to
cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell for all
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive